well perhaps surprisingly considering
the global climate change summit
starting in glasgow in just a few days
time today's budget was not dominated by
spending on climate the government did
of course announce a whole raft of new
climate measures including its net zero
strategy just last week so was it
inevitable given the post covered
environment that green measures would be
overshadowed in today's budget kate to
you first your reaction to
that think that the climate emergency
should have been at the heart of this
autumn budget uh obviously there were a
raft of policies announced last week but
without the money to back up those
policies
they're just words on paper and that
doesn't lead to any action at all and
that means that the climate targets that
those policies are supposed to be
hitting just simply aren't going to be
reached without the money to back them
up it felt very much like rishi sunak
was much more interested in investing in
prosecco than he was the planet
and stuart your thoughts after today's
budget of course a lot of criticism at
the lack of green spending of course
just days ahead of cop
as the host nation what did you make of
that was that odd to you the optics of
that perhaps
i think one of the things for me is an
and kate touched on this you you can't
look at the budget in isolation i think
you've got to look at it alongside the
the net zero strategy
and look there are still some big
funding gaps there that need to be
filled as kate said but i also look at
it through the lens of of my sector my
industry there were some things in the
budget so for example the announcement
about business rate investment relief
for on-site renewables or green
technologies that will definitely help
our sector get towards net zero there is
still a lot more to be done um but it
wasn't all disappointment but there are
still those funding gaps missing
and a strategy without funding isn't uh
isn't a strategy we've got to have the
funding that goes with it as well
yeah kate see you next as stuart
referenced there you know the government
has allocated 30 billion pounds to
create new green industries of the
future since march as the chancellor
referenced once again today do you think
that budget day is simply far too
complex
a day far too complex in terms of its
level of announcements in public
spending to make those sorts of big
green announcements
i think no because i do think that the
green announcement should have been very
clear from the outset the moment that he
stood up he should have been talking
about the climate crisis we're days away
from cop we can see that extreme weather
events are happening today they're
happening every single day all around
the world we're hearing from un
scientists uh with new reports every
single day saying how
we
the uk but also globally are not hitting
the climate targets that we should be in
order to try and keep temperature rises
to 1.5 the chancellor
and this government do need to be doing
much more than making announcements and
saying targets they need to be
allocating the money to back them up
and stuart just lastly on this issue
what do you make of the decision to cut
air passenger duty by 50 on domestic
flights of course fuel duties are almost
at a record high at the moment uh
low-income families are really
struggling did was this a surprise to
you
i'm trying to say it was a surprise as
someone who actually took a decision a
few years ago not to take domestic
flights precisely for
the environmental reasons
i was very surprised by that one and
yeah that came a bit left field i
thought
you